[Music]
Hilary Clinton's new book what happened
hit stores on September 12 and her
publisher promise that she will let
loose about her experience as a woman in
politics in a way that she's never done
before will it help her poll numbers I
doubt it
throughout the 2016 campaign both
Clinton and Donald Trump were viewed
negatively by most voters that's still
true today in a new NBC news/wall Street
Journal poll only thirty percent had a
positive view of her while 53 percent
had a negative one Trump's numbers were
similar Hillary did best in public
opinion polls when she was a senator
from New York and when she was Secretary
of State but questions about her honesty
her establishment ties and an
unexpectedly vigorous challenge from
Bernie Sanders her 2016 candidacy
Hillary Clinton says she is letting her
guard down with her new book and she
takes some shots at Sanders and Joe
Biden in it but it's unlikely to improve
her poll numbers that's a difficult task
to learn more about my take on Hillary
Clinton check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI